عند اجراء اول تجربه لصاروخ صارمات
البالستي في ابريل الماضي قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان هذا الصاروخ
سيجعل اعداء روسيا يتوقفون ويفكرون يزن
صاروخ صارمات الذي قال الرئيس بوتين انه
لا مثيل له ولن يكون له مثيل فتره طويله
من الزمن 220 طنا ويبلغ طوله اكثر من 35
مترا يبلغ مداهما بين 10,000 وثمانيه عشر
الف كيلو متر ما يجعله قادرا على ضرب اي
بقعه في الارض يستطيع حمل عشره رؤوس
النوويه ويمكنه اطلاق حموله القصوى تبلغ
50 ميجا من ماده تي ان تي
صمم صاروخ صارمات للافلات من انظمه الدفاع
المضاده للثواريخ من خلال تقنيات لا تمنح
هذه الانظمه الا وقتا قصيرا لبدء التتبع
في مقابل هذا الصاروخ تطور الولايات
المتحده منذ 2014 صاروخا عابرا للقارات
يتوقعوا ان يفوق مدى هذا الصاروخ
5,500 كم ويستطيع الوصول الى اي هدف في
الارض خلال ثلاثين دقيقه سيتم تزود
الصاروخ براس نووي حربي ويستطيع صاروه
اطلاق الراس النووي في منتصف الطريق
لينطلق الراس في اتجاه الهدف يتوقع ان
تجرى اول تجربه لهذا الصاروخ الامريكي عام
2023 وان يدخل الخدمه عام 2029
[موسيقى]